[Musica]
tutti benvenuti solite storie bossi sono
solo io e il video lo farò io ci sono
anch'io non vi preoccupate
oggi i video super divertente vi
ricordate lo scorso di cui dovevamo
comprare tutto quello che riuscivamo a
sigla bar e io ho chiesto a vitale di
comprarvi un cane ormai mi ha portato
questo coso freddo non ricordo io ho
visto il video
l'avete visto dovrei vederlo dopo questo
video comunque avete richiesto in
tantissimi di fare un video in cui sia
un orlino con questo cagnolino per 24
ore quindi andrò a ignorare berlino per
24 ore che un altro video di un altro
mese speciale che chiesto tantissimo e
la sostituirà con questo capito che non
sappiamo come reagire a un berlino
questo caso perché a quanto pare questo
cane fa tante cose si muove mangia la
terza primi ora andiamo subito ad
aprirlo e a farlo funzionare
e poi facciamo entrare mirino vediamo
come reagisce secondo te come reagisce
berlino
ho paura che se lo voglia mangiare
leccese che una mezza romagna oppure
avrà paura oppure penserà che il suo
fratellino
troppo curioso provate indovinare nei
commenti come reagirà sky ragazzino
abbiamo tirato fuori montato ora andiamo
ad accenderlo vediamo un po arrivato e
sta guardando con un occhietto furbo sta
già pensando che cos'è quel cagnolone
gigante
siamo pronti a metà riunione ora vado ad
accenderlo devo prima premere
l'interruttore
vediamo un po nervino lido c'è un
fratino un nuovo maggiolino
sembra contento per questo scodinzolando
stai cercando di onorare il sederino i
cani taglia come il vero che una tv nos
assomiglia al piccolo aiutante di babbo
natale
quindi sì
[Musica]
berlina vaghi devi fare male sopra
teheran non lo mordere merlino tv ora
dovrò ignorare merlino per 24 ore non so
come reagirà ma a partire da ora dovrò
completamente ignorarlo sarà difficile
anche per me perché vogliono portare a
cercare la finta che questo mio nuovo
cagnolino sarà un numero ridotto che gli
inviti accarezza vedi mostre dai la
zampata
berlino il rassegnato mi sembra un po
triste berlino da berlino mi sta recando
mattino guarda di un occhio geloso che
chiarirà che il premio nota tonino bello
il più nuovo cagnolino artigianale
progetto lo spazzino vediamo ehi ma più
bravo di berlino nel prendere le cose ci
sono le crocchette berlino già devoto
[Musica]
tieni mangia la forchetta
berlino ha una faccia un po sconvolta
sembra molto triste berlino non capisse
da un libro non è per te queste sei il
mio cagnolino che bravo merlino non si
ruba lo stessi lo tieni un'altra
forchetta possiamo ignorare di porta d
oriente
ecco qua per limitare tanti martini
geloso berlino suo nel suo strumento
musicale
mi dispiace ma ti devo ignorare
9.000 cari piede e l'etica che bravo
stesso cagnolino si fa accarezzare
evidente tipici di chi vaccinate il suo
cane di unire tutto il cielo
[Musica]
berlino è diventato triste ma non posso
andare accarezzando perché dopo ignora o
meglio lo possa utilizzare per dire
sconvolto
bravo finora che si mangia quella sia un
cucciolo iniziato a giocare state
l'indurre l'espulsione
ma clio non sembra mai un cane
intelligente forse per averli
gambardella sono forse uno per produrre
ma mai pieno e cosola diciamo che cosa
fa
[Musica]
berlino che stai facendo lascia migliore
che no hay è insomma il mio nuovo cambio
lido insistenza un geloso endocrino
[Musica]
devo ignorarla
infine mezzo penso che lo utilizza un
attimino
mm hg
un bagno di ritirare la lingua poverina
mamma ma in sauna berlino dispettoso di
62 una via non lo devi trovare il mio
cagnolino e si deve migliorare i quali
il mulino berlino è diventato
gelosissima io non posso neanche
calcolarlo devo ignorarlo carlino è
gelosissimo vuole mordere il mio
cucciolo nemmeno non posso dire se il
cardo perché devo migliorarlo cerchiamo
di mordano orecchie le zampe che stai
facendo
ho cercato di mordermi la lingua senso
perché forse ci vuole dare un bacino
[Musica]
da averli alba sto cercando di darmi la
zappa per per farsi calcolare buy e devo
ignorarmi con il mio cagnolino che l'ok
arezzo non vedo nessun altro cagnolino
come più bello il mio cagnolino
bello il mio cagnolino paese mio
cagnolino
questo è il mio unico cagnolino siamo
violino via
[Musica]
non di mangiare la coda forlì fino a che
questo non è il mio cagnolino ma proprio
cattiva berlino è diventato talmente
geloso che l'ha buttato a terra dal
letto
non è possibile berlino maranto
diventato amico perché mi porterò a
termine
povero cagnoni a berlino impazzito non
riesce più a contenere la gelosia
berlino ma è zoppa l'ha salutata povero
carioni non vuole più alzarlo a jesi
chilo di troppo che ora per finire la
challenge
prendiamo il cagnolino e vediamo se
berlino si rende conto che solo un
pupazzo che non è un cagnolino vero
ecco fa l'ho messo suo vediamo cosa fa
guarda merlino e finto veri e finto
guarda e finto ma va bene così
divertente non mi aspettavo che berlino
diventasse così geloso
[Musica]
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere altri challenge con berlino e
fateci sapere nei commenti che altre
challenge video divertenti volete vedere
con il mio cagnolino in linea e ora vi
lascio qualcosa per salire su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
il caso quella che preferite e vorrei
[Musica]